- [Voiceover] Alright,
now let's tackle part c.
Use quantitative reasoning,
including equations as needed,
to develop an expression
for the new final position of the block.
Express your answer in terms of D.
Alright, I'm gonna set up a
little table here for part c.
Oops, sorry about that.
Sometimes my pen is not
functioning properly.
Alright so part c.
Let me set up two scenarios.
So I have scenario one.
Scenario one, where we
compress the spring,
our delta x is equal to d,
and then we have scenario two,
scenario two, where we
compress the spring by
twice as much, is equal to two d,
and let me set up my table now,
so, just like that and like this,
and let's just think about a few things.
So the first thing I wanna think about is
the potential energy,
so the potential energy
when the spring is compressed.
So potential energy
when spring compressed.
When, I'll just write
compressed, when compressed.
Well in this scenario I'll
call it the potential energy
for scenario one, it's
equal to one half times
the spring constant, times how
much we compress it squared.
Now what about scenario two?
This potential energy
is going to be equal to
one half times the spring
constant, times how much
we compress it, it's now
twice as much, squared,
well this is equal to one half
times the spring constant,
times four d squared,
and I can out the four up front,
this is equal to four times
one half, four times one half,
times our spring
constant, times d squared,
which is equal to four
times the potential energy
when we just compress the spring by d.
So we already see a little
bit of what we talked about
in part b, you compress
your spring twice as much,
you're going to have four
times the potential energy,
because the potential energy
doesn't grow proportionately
with how much you compress
it, it grows with the square
of how much you compress it.
Alright, now let's think
about kinetic energy
Kinetic energy when x is equal to zero,
so right when the spring,
when we lose contact
with the spring, the
spring is no longer pushing
on the block, well our
kinetic energy is going to be
equal to what our potential
energy was when the spring
was actually compressed.
Another way of thinking about
it, all that potential energy
has now been turned into kinetic energy.
Now what about over here?
Well, the kinetic energy in this scenario,
like we just saw before,
that's gonna be equal to the
potential energy when the
spring was compressed.
All of that potential energy
gets turned into kinetic energy
and this is equal to four
times u one, four times
the potential energy in
scenario one, which is the same
thing as four times, which
is equal to four times
the kinetic energy in scenario one.
So we have four times the kinetic energy.
Four times kinetic energy,
kinetic, kinetic energy.
So then we have stopping
distance, stopping,
stopping distance.
We know here this is three d and we know,
and then we can say "What's
this?", this question mark.
Well let's just think a
little bit about this.
We know that if we have
that kinetic energy
at x equals zero,
so we know that k one plus
the work done by friction,
so let me make it clear,
this right over here,
that is work done by friction,
work done by friction,
and it's gonna be negative work
cause the force of friction
is acting in the direction
opposite of the change in x,
so the kinetic energy plus
the work done by friction
is going to be equal to zero.
This work cancels out all of this energy.
When we think about it, it's
turning it all into heat.
And so let's think about what
the work done by friction
is equal to.
Well the work done by friction
is equal to, is equal to,
the coefficient of friction
times the mass of the block,
times the gravitational
field, times how far,
over what distance that
force, this right over here
is the force of friction,
times over what distance
that force was applied, so times three d.
And to be clear, this force is going in
the opposite direction of our change in x,
so because of that this
will be a negative,
and so we can say, we can
say that the kinetic energy
at x equals zero, and now I
can just write it as minus
mu, the coefficient of
friction, times mass, times
the gravitational field, times
three d is equal to zero.
We can add this to both
sides and we can get
k one is equal to mu times
m times g times three d,
and if you wanted to
solve for distance here,
you can divide both sides
by the force of friction.
So divide both sides by mu
times m times g, and you get
three d, and I'm just
swapping the sides here,
is going to be equal to the
amount of kinetic energy we have
right as x equals zero,
divided by mu times m times g
and you can just view this
as the force of friction.
The force, I'll just call it
the force of friction right over there.
So if you wanna figure
out your stopping distance
you just figure out your kinetic energy,
right when you, right at x equals zero,
right when you start entering
into the frictiony part of
your platform and then you divide that by
the force of friction,
and that will give you
your distance traveled.
So the distance here, distance,
so I can just put some
arrows right over here,
our distance is going to be
equal to k two divided by the force of,
the force of friction.
Well k two is equal to four times k one,
is equal to four times k one.
and our force of friction
is going to be the same
We have the same coefficient of friction,
we have the same mass, we have the same
gravitational field, so
divided by force of friction,
and this we already know, k one
divided by force of friction
is equal to three d, so this
is all going to be equal to
four, this is going to
be four times three d,
three d, which is equal to 12 d, 12 d.
So this is all a
mathematical way of saying
you compress it twice as
much, you're going to have
four times the potential energy when your
spring is compressed, which
means you're going to have
four times the kinetic
energy at x equals zero,
which means it is going to
take, you're going to have
four times the stopping
distance, so instead of stopping
at three d or in six d as
what the student proposed,
you are now stopping at 12 d, so that is
our stopping distance.
Did we answer all of, yeah
we answered all of part c.
Use quantitative reasoning,
including equations as needed,
to develop an expression
for the new final position
of the block.
Express your answer in terms of d.
Yep, feel good about that.